nous allons aujourd'hui parler des
femmes battues un sujet dont la presse
s'est fait largement écho depuis
quelques semaines et en particulier
depuis l'apparition du livre des rimes
bizet cris moins fort les voisins vont
entendre
il faut dire qu'en france ce livre a été
accueillie avec un certain scepticisme
le secrétaire d'état à la condition
féminine madame françoise giroud a même
à un moment donné semblait penser qu'en
france précisément ce phénomène
n'existait pas alors en france les
femmes battues se plaignent t-elle
vraiment de ce traitement
pourquoi ont-elles attendu si longtemps
pour se manifester
est-ce que la violence ne devient pas de
manière générale de plus en plus
insupportable est-ce que l'explication
n'est pas plutôt qu'une femme battue et
quelqu'un qui ne sait ni que faire ni
quoi faire ni où aller
mais au fait y at il vraiment en france
des femmes battues en ce moment des
femmes battues
j'ignore totalement médias sony a
certainement eu depuis toujours c'est
pas d'aujourd'hui a toujours existé ça
dépanne battu il y en aura toujours
et certains silences sur la quantité et
il y à des femmes battues c'est sûr il y
avait des hommes gayssot il ya des
inhumains partout où les gens pensent
que comptable miscibles non je ne mets
pas pas du tout absolument pas il
vaudrait mieux que ça cesse je n'ai
jamais battu ma femme je vous jure que
c'est vrai je vous jure que c'est elle
qui me bats
évidemment il ya des hommes qui s'en va
tu riais ouais je jeu j'ai entendu j'ai
pas vu mais delwendé pas mon salaire
équivalent d'une fourchette nous
l'achète à la tête de leur mari ça se
présente ça mon petit pas mais les
dealers
non je permettrai pas à ma femme de le
faire d'abord dans certaines
circonstances oui au xxème siècle c
désolant puis le monde est monde des
femmes mènent le ministre alors je vais
bien ils ont motivé leur a certainement
plus france puisque les femmes mais des
hommes valeureux peut-être puisque dan
callikan je n'ai jamais battu ma femme
ma femme mes enfants mes vertus non plus
d'ailleurs
voilà on est au courant qu'il ya des
femmes battues en france je pense que
c'est ce qu'il faut s'attendre des
relations entre les êtres humains et
vous monsieur vous êtes mariés oui vous
l'avez été souvent votre femme
non jamais
jamais jamais jamais amis
non jamais jamais jamais et même pas
avec une rose comme personnellement je
vois pas la mienne gac parfois j'en ai
envie vous avez déjà bâti votre faim
battu ce disque 8 et 10 ans oui
un coup malheureux elle est méritée pas
spécialement non un coup de colère et
l'humilité
alors là ça c'est une chose
oui abate c'est surprenant ça ne
surprend pas tellement
votre femme des petites jupes 4 x ou y
en a qui viennent des failles sont un
peu plus marquée que d'habitude alors
c'est sûrement un accident de ménage son
foyer dans une parole et c'est possible
des femmes battues je connais pas s'ils
ont envie oui il ya des femmes qui
aiment sa part en europe habitude
peut-être y avait 1 km battu il y en a
qui aiment pas regarder à qui sont pas
battus parce qu'elles n'ont pas besoin
d'être battue mais je sais qu'il ya des
femmes qui sont battre et si je disais
que moi je bats ma femme
oui soit plus gentils et puis amoureuse
de moi qu'ils ont compris les gens
pensaient que si mettons moi si je veux
tu as plus ma femme mais je suis sûr que
la famille l'amour et candia log mais
pas possible j'ai vu quelques dessins
humoristiques avec encre et entrez vous
ça bien dans la tête savez ces dessins
avec un marteau alors à certaines 20000
hors fo falloir faire entrer à coups de
poing c'est le résultat du vieux statut
patriarcal de l'homme
il ya là un droit qui paraît une
évidence à beaucoup de gens et keith qui
sont tout à fait incapable de remettre
en question les relations réelles de
l'homme et de la femme et s'apercevoir
que la femme est aussi est une personne
comme l'écrivait la revue esprit
il ya bien des années bien qu'il y avait
des femmes battues ça on le savait et je
voulais demander qu'on enchaîne tout sur
les téléspectatrices qui réagissent très
violemment depuis le début de ce
reportage nicole m'adapter ces messieurs
ont l'air de sourire quand on parle des
femmes battues et du problème des femmes
battues et il ya une certaine ironie
vous-même l'avait subi cet état de fait
est ce que vous avez envie d'en rire
maintenant non les réflexions que ces
messieurs font rire parce qu'elles sont
ridicules et quand c'est ridicule ça
apporte arrive autrement le fait d'être
béthune et ne porte pas à rire du tout
du tout surtout quand on lit vite et le
fait qu'ils disent que les femmes bat
quelquefois leur mari ça me fait penser
aux desseins du bus est énorme femme
avec un petit mari terrorisé bien écouté
dans la vie moi j'en ai je n'en n'ai
jamais jamais vous avez été donc une
femme battue madame depuis le début de
votre mariage comment ça s'est passé
non je crois pas que je sois que j'ai le
statut de femme battue non je crois pas
non j'ai dû commettre quelques fautes
enfin vous alors les hommes estiment que
ce sont des fautes
peut-être welt il une femme disciplinés
une femme soumise comme ça existe dans
certains pays sous développés mais je
pense pas qu'en france ça corresponde à
l'idée on va se faire d'une femme
pourquoi vous avez accepté donc de nous
apporter votre témoignage
vous avez demandé à être dans l'ombre
est ce qu'il vous reste une crainte et
où c'est par pudeur ses propos du tout
non c'est parce que je ne suis pas seul
concerné autrement je n'ai aucune
crainte
c'est votre fille qui est un concernant
le temps vous oui elle est concernée en
même temps que moi bien sûr on va enfin
je tiens bataillon rentrer dans les
détails
madame j pour vous c'est la même chose
vous avez été une femme heureuse vous
n'avez qu'à 18 ans 15 ans 20 ans et
comme d un coup tout s'est dégradé tout
là contre selectra dit pourquoi bien
comment vous expliquez c'est très simple
après tout mon mari n'avait plus la
situation a perdu sa situation de vendée
des besoins des enfants il se sentait
très lâche de plus voulu assumer ses
responsabilités c'est tout simplement ça
s'est plus senti capable d'élever et
surtout de subvenir aux besoins de cinq
enfants et c'est pour ça qu'il vous a
frappé c'est pour ça qu'il m'a frappé
c'est à dire pour cette raison qu'il a
quitté la maison
vous êtes donc maintenant une femme
libre depuis combien de temps libre
depuis deux ans et demi et vous n'avez
pas peur qu'il récidive qui leur est
joliment pas absolument pas y revient
voir les enfants 8 et 10 francs par an
vous avez subi ces sévices pendant
combien de temps man pendant deux ans
pendant deux ans pendant lesquels je
j'ai temporisé j'essayais croyants à
nous
une folie passagère c'est simplement
lorsque me suis rendu compte que
véritablement une changerait pas au
contraire que l'âge
oui tout en oeuvre pour mieux séparer
séparions est ce que l'une et l'autre ce
sera ma dernière question vous êtes
arrivé à analyser le pourquoi de cette
attitude
oui madame t oui oui je pense que
c'était un constat d'échec de la part de
l'homme vous aussi
la dame denis vous vous êtes vous êtes à
visage découvert brethmas le témoignage
que peut nous apporter aujourd'hui c'est
celui c'est la vue de l'enfant puisque
vous avez eu un père qui a bâti votre
mère quelle est la réaction d'un enfant
vous aviez quel age 2 que je suis née
jusqu'à l'âge de 15 ans que je suis
parti travailler dès ma naissance dès
que l'âge que j'ai pu comprendre je vais
toujours mon père lever la main avec
tout ce qui est tombée sur a rapporté ce
mamère et pendant tout l avait quatre
enfants s'était pas épinoy on voulait la
défense puis c'était nous qui les remet
à sion aussi un âne qui bat sa femme dao
si ses enfants pour vivre encore une
patte j'étais la fille peut siéger que
trois de ses trois frères j'étais
confuse et pas tellement le vu la main
sur moi mais en voyant tapé ma mère
comme ça c'est comme s'il m'avait donné
des des coûts a même pas ce que c'est
c'est inimaginable il faut il faut vivre
être avoir vécu ça être enfant avoir
vécu ça havas rues en terre comme ça moi
je suis pas je dis parce que mon père
s'était pas parce qu'il buvait il n'ya
rien c'était par pure méchanceté et sa
sa méchanceté
il buvait pas
rien du tout c'était pas envie de battre
plutôt que les femmes monnaie raconte et
s'est marié avec avec lui au bout d'un
mois de mariage et la mine gif le maire
n'a pas eu la réaction de se défendre
après dire maintenant puisque elle m'a
laissé mettre une vif tout de suite
après je peux laisser partir a bien
réagi et puis voilà mais c'est par ici
par ici vous êtes notre téléspectateurs
aujourd'hui vous êtes un ancien
magistrat monsieur vous avez entendu les
confessions de notre témoin vous même
avez été confronté souvent dans votre
carrière à ce genre de situation et vous
déplorez que la justice en soit avisé
peut-être un petit peu trop tard c'est
exact j'ai d'ailleurs une conception
plus généralisé de du débat
d'aujourd'hui parce que ce que nous
venons d'entendre ce sont des cas
particuliers
moi je connais une quantité de cas j'ai
eu l'occasion de les connaître
professionnellement et il faudrait
d'abord s'entendre sur ce qu'on appelle
une femme battue une femme qui reçoit
occasionnellement quelques paires de
claques
est ce que c'est une femme battue je ne
pense pas que ce soit ça l'objet du
débat d'aujourd'hui une femme battue et
à mon avis c'est une femme qui est
constamment battue
or je connais des cas de malheureuses
qui sont on peut le dire réduite en
esclavage et se fait ce phénomène se
produit pendant des années et pendant
des années la malheureuse n'ose rien
dire et subit les coups et les traîner
par terre par les cheveux elle est
frappée à coups de pieds dans le ventre
elle reçoit des délits coup avec un fer
à repasser
je vous donne des précisions de ce que
vous voulez dire qu'il ya des degrés
dans la cruelle en paille à des degrés
évident en aura bien des à votre voisine
madame paddec est donc aussi une
ancienne m'excuser de cette expression
si vous estimez qu'on peut franchir les
échelons dans ce genre de dans ce champ
de chose ou qui a pas tellement en soi
une paire de gifles c'est aussi
insultant la première cardiologie fait
insulte un déplore ce qu'il ya c'est que
l'on n'a pas là on n'a pas la
possibilité tout du moins n'a pas le
courage de réagir à ce moment là parce
que d'abord parce qu'on aime son mari
parce que quand on est jeune on est bête
on aime son mari alors du moment qu'on
leur saveur
n'importe quoi lui a presque permis mais
c'est la première fois que vous donne
une gifle et cassé une bouteille de
limonade sur la tête ils commencent
réponse il a demandé à marie claude si
la première gifle
ce n'est pas le début d'une belle
carrière de femme battue justement je
pense que comme le disait la femme qui
est là une gifle c'est quelque chose de
très très humiliant et que si on s'en
défend pas aussitôt en se révoltant
c'est sûr que ça doit s'enchaîner avec
des coûts beaucoup plus violents après
moi je crois que dans mon cas par
exemple ça n'a pas dépassé la gifle
parce que j'avais au même moment les
moyens de partir de chez moi et de me
retrouver avec des femmes et de faire ce
que j'avais envie de faire avec elle
justement vous représentez ici la
librairie des femmes et vous mener une
action pour faire quelque chose
justement contre ce phénomène les femmes
battues
qu'est ce que vous faites en pratique
est ce qu'on peut vous appeler et dans
ce cas la caution mais la première chose
pratiques qu'on ait fait c'est d'éviter
ce livre puisque là les familles disent
comment elles sont battues d'autres
disent comment elles ont fait des
maisons pour que ces femmes s'y réfugier
puisse reprendre des forces et après lui
t il non plus ces serpents dans ces
situations là et ça c'est une chose qui
prend sa place dans tout l'ensemble la
lutte des femmes en france et en
angleterre et dans tous les pays et en
ce moment nous l'avons édité parce que
nous étions nombreuses à avoir été battu
à savoir que les femmes n'étaient et à
essayer de se donner les moyens de
lutter contre ça bien vous avez aidé des
femmes et notamment une
qu'on appellera à madame x qui est
présente ses plateaux vous avez donc été
secouru par la librairie des femmes êtes
mariés depuis longtemps maintenant et ça
s'est produit tout à fait après le
mariage assez bon après cinq ans de
mariage et c'était en fait pour la suite
tout événement où j'étais plus petit à
petit disons pour prendre mon
indépendance parce que parce que je me
sentais je commence à apprendre un petit
peu confiance je veux chanter brel mais
dijon
ça s'est passé à ce moment là est-ce que
vous avez conscience d'avoir accepté à
tort une première gt qui aurait entraîné
les autres
disons que pour moi ce n'était pas une
première jeudi chassées tête c'était des
concessions est davantage
par exemple une indépendance économique
je travaillais avec mon mari
le bien-être chaque pack j'enquêtais ans
sont bons et petit à petit voulant
prendre mon indépendance
disons que ce n'était pas une cible
c'était un autre du moment où j'étais
produit par des coûts qui s'est traduit
par des coûts mais sur le commissaire
6000 je voudrais savoir si vous pensez
vous citez des deux vrais dans l'enclos
t et si les nombreux cas vous avez pu
voir puisque vous représentez ici
le syndicat des commissaires de paris si
ces nombreux cas peuvent être classifiés
si je puis dire ce qui à la ji les coûts
l'épousé blé oui il est évident que ce
qu'a dit monsieur parizeau tout à
l'heure est vrai il ya des degrés dans
la violence et ça personne ne peut le
nier parce que les les blessures qui
nous qui peuvent en résulter sont
extrêmement différentes suivant la
gravité des coups donnés alors ce que je
voudrais dire quand même un prologue
c'est qu'on aurait pu penser que le fait
que les jeunes en général repousse le
mariage estime de vivre le mot
concubinage et peut-être déplacer
aujourd'hui mais enfin de vivre à de se
marier
eh bien elle aurait pu faire disparaître
les violences or on s'aperçoit dans les
commissariats que bien au contraire on
constate largement autant de violence
chez les couples qui ne sont pas mariés
et ils on constate également que ces
couples se séparent aussi difficilement
sinon plus que les couples qui sont
mariées legacy colloque tout à l'heure
mais je voudrais vous dire tout de même
que de manière générale les femmes
battues qui nous ont contactés nous
disent tout que dans les commissariats
on est reçu avec un petit sourire et
sans être pris très au sérieux quelle
que soit la gravité parfois des des
blessures non alors là je voudrais
rétablir
les faits et les choses telles qu'elles
sont enfin je parle pour ce qui concerne
mon service d'abord premièrement dans le
service dans ce responsable
ce sont des femmes qui accueille les
plaignants et les plaignantes
y avez vous êtes le seul qui me sérieux
comme cela le jury quentin rouger les
suites voltaire je suis pas le seul mais
lorsqu'une femme se présente dans un
commissariat supposant qu'elles viennent
dire mon mari m'a battu bon la
fonctionnaire qui va les recevoir va lui
dire madame qu'est ce que vous avez
comme blessures bon ben vous dire j'ai
des bleus là j'ai mal dans le dos j'ai
ceci et cela
bon alors à partir de ce moment là le
fonctionnaire conformément à la loi
d'ailleurs à lui seul à revenir
excusez-moi de vous interrompre et si le
commissaire nous allons revenir ajouté
surtout cet aspect juridique mais je
voulais parler du côté humain car toutes
les femmes qui nous ont écrit nous ont
dit que dès qu'elle mettait le pied dans
un commissariat
elle sentait une certaine ironie jouer
savoir si vous étiez d'accord c'est à
dire que les mois je ne suis pas
d'accord lorsque je reçois une femme
pour un problème qui lui est particulier
et bien je fais comme avec les autres
plaignants je les écoute le mieux que je
peux mais
il ya effectivement dans la psychologie
des français en général
cette espèce de deux voiles dit entoure
la vie familiale
il ya un adage judiciaire qui dit que le
droit n'a pas à s'occuper des secrets
d'alcôve par exemple bientôt nos
téléspectatrices qui donc ont été
manipulés à comme dirai comment avez
vous été reçus et bien avec un peu
d'ironie ci contre est pas méchante
d'ailleurs ou simplement vous savez ça
va s'arranger c'est une petite scène de
ménage
tout le monde le connaît ça me retourner
chez vous paternaliste tout à fait
l'attitude des agents des gendarmes ont
fait tout à fait paternaliste un mot ça
va soyez gentils ne contrarier pas votre
mari ça s'arrange pas maxim gaudette
psycho là comment vous à tapoter cette
réaction
deux officiers de police de nantes et
sympathique
je crois que enfin on peut dire beaucoup
de choses on va essayer de se dirige
très vite et on développera mais quelque
chose qu'il faut pas oublier c'est que
il circule une certaine façon de dire
qu'il faut battre les fans de la manière
suivante
batta femmes même si je ne sais pas
pourquoi elle est le set et ça c'est
quelque chose qui est latent dans une
certaine misogynie qui existent et qui
fait que quand une femme battue se
présente on y pense alors que ça amène
un sourire peut-être que ce soit
souhaitable évidemment c'est tout à fait
autre chose mais il y a certainement
aussi un autre aspect c'est cet
organisme antagonismes masculin féminin
qui existent et qui fait que forcément
je crois que dans certains cas il serait
souhaitable que des femmes sont reçus
par des femmes et les hommes par des
hommes même si les hommes font
parfaitement leur travail et le fond en
l'appliquant parfaitement la loi ça ne
change rien c'est pas pareil docteur
benchetrit vous êtes médecin généraliste
comment accueillez-vous nous sommes
bâtis elle est votre rôle de nits et
bien schématiquement nous recevrons les
femmes battues de deux manières ou bien
le cas et pas tant visible
les voisins le savent et on vient nous
réclamer avant tout un certificat
médical en vue d'une procédure à
entreprendre ou bien et c'est un cas
plus plus secrets plus intéressant si je
puis dire c'est au cours d'une
conversation dans un état dépressif on
s'aperçoit que l'infâme vous livre
désaveu et petit à petit passionnant on
arrive à lui arracher des aveux et des
vérités qu'elle n'oserait pas dire du
remblai alors là évidemment le rôle
n'est plus un rôle formel il s'agit
d'entreprendre une psychothérapie de
connaître les causes et d'aller aussi
loin et sociales concours du mari dans
ces cas là eh bien ce n'est qu'une que
la première partie d'une enquête très
donc très minutieuse et il faut dire
aussi que très souvent au départ il ya
un élément pathologique indiscutable les
maris qui bat comme ça par plaisir les
femmes ça n'est pas tellement courant en
pourcentage on peut dire que le cas est
plutôt réduit par contre des éléments
pathologique à la base de cet état sont
évidents ne serait-ce que l'alcoolisme
qu'on pourrait invoquer comme première
cause justement c'est l'alcoolisme est
une cause
qui revient le plus souvent est ce que
ces derniers n'en mène justement qui est
du point de vue médical il est évident
que c'est un cas qui nous intéresse donc
nous sommes portés à a étudié ce cas
avec des attentions
l'alcoolisme est un état pathologique
tout le monde le sait et l'alcoolique
passe par des tanks / dépressif est en
phase dépressive il a besoin de se
libérer il a besoin d'agir violemment et
cette violence est en quelque sorte
imputable non pas au sujet lui-même mais
à sa situation de malades l'adapter vous
voulez intervenir je trouve que c'est
encore une manière de restreindre le
problème d'ailleurs on restera toujours
pour essayer en plus d'atténuer la
responsabilité de l'homme
il est alcoolique il frappe c'est pas sa
faute son état pathologique c'est un
malade
or c'est faux c'est parfaitement faux
vous avez des hommes qui ne sont
absolument pas les colis qui sont des
gens tout à fait équilibrée dans la
ville qui frappent leurs femmes
ça n'a rien à voir avec alors oui
certains des messieurs grandes idées
voudrais répondre je voudrais dire deux
choses c'est que quelles sont les causes
adv echoes à la base c'est toujours un
aveu d'impuissance
c'est un aveu d'impuissance pas
forcément d'ailleurs au niveau sexuel
comme c'est une des causes mais ça peut
être par exemple un homme qui adore une
femme celle-ci lui échappe parce qu'ils
sont qu'elle n'aime pas autant qu'il
aime il va l'abattre va l'abattre parce
que parce qu'il peut plus faire
autrement elle s'emballe vallée avec un
autre bon il
là bas il peut aller jusqu'à la tv ça
qu'on appelle un état très très logis
mais cette évidence qui se disent bien
vous allez aussi le problème de
l'incommunicabilité c'est une des causes
envers yannick et enfin ils vont tenir
on a une dernière invitée qui est martin
le pérou et qui représente ici sos
femmes alternative à leur destin en
alternative coin
c'est une association qui fonctionne
collégialement et j'insiste sur
collégialement parce que normalement sur
ce plateau nous devions être au minimum
trois personnes et puis cela du reste
avait été plus ou moins entendu avec
voeckler qui est ici et puis finalement
monsieur gara a limité notre nombre à
une seule personne
la demoiselle nous sommes déjà 13 sur le
plateau tour nous sommes pas ici pour
faire un débat n'est pas de nous à
l'épargné intérieure de l alternative et
de son rôle comme on a parlé du rôle de
la nuit de sos femmes alternative ce2
créer un centre qui pas fonctionner et
pour l'instant nous avons une antenne
téléphonique avec des médecins et avec
des avocats et l'intérêt justement sur
ce plateau de plusieurs personnes
auraient été qu'il y ait des médecins
qui ne souhaitent pas ma dose unique
qu'ils soient là d'accord et puis
justement puisse présenter leurs primes
du côté si vous aussi vous quand il
risque d'en être obligés d'interrompre
l'émission 90 animaux mans nantes et
rennes l'a alors je crois qu'on peut
passer nos problèmes du pourquoi nicole
des femmes battues avec les
téléspectateurs
oui ce qui m explique madame madame
madame j pouvez-vous savoir à quel
moment et pourquoi votre mari a commencé
à vous battre puisque pendant vingt ans
vous avez été parfaitement heureuse avec
lui et rien ne laissait prévoir
absolument rien et simplement je vous
dis c'est que c'est un complexe
d'infériorité vis-à-vis de ses enfants
vis-à-vis de moi-même
dès l'instant mon mari s'est sentie
incapable de subvenir à leurs besoins
matériels morale aussi était terminée il
a cherché hier que quelqu'un qui n'avait
pas une personne qui n'a d'aucune
entrave qui n'avait pas d'enfant qui n'a
aucune entrave le voit que ça se passe
dans tous les milieux monsieur yvan
didier houi parfaitement on a déterminé
que 55 12 7% de la population qui bat et
dans les classes moyennes et non pas
forcément dans les classes lustres comme
on pourrait peut-être 22 façon
simpliste le croire c'est pas du tout le
cas bien justement qui sue qui sont ces
hommes qui battent les femmes c'est une
question qu'on peut poser à au docteur
benchetrit puisque vous semblez et de
collaborer avec les maris dans ces cas
là et bien là collaboration n'est pas
spécifiquement réservée en mari mais en
réalité cette le mot battre une femme
est un peu vague
si on précise la question il ya deux
aspects il y à la violence gratuite et
il ya la violence motivée et bien la
violence motivée
ce n'est que personne qui compte est que
je dis viens à l'instant de parler de
complexe d'infériorité
voyez vous que les choses ne sont pas si
simple quand on cherche à tout prix un
bouc émissaire qu'on veut absolument
qu'ils un responsable et on ne veut pas
admettre qu'il puisse y avoir des
raisons qui échappent à la personne en
question bon quoi qu'il en soit il est
extrêmement c'était échantillon de gens
qui battent leurs femmes est assez vaste
marie claude vézina il ya plusieurs
choses me dise nsu qui vont acheter
heureusement il ya la première chose qui
fait que ce sont les hommes malades qui
battent bec les femmes alors là on peut
remarquer que c'est pas de discuter si
les hommes complexe je sais pas quoi
c'est le cas de tout le monde d'être et
névrosé les hommes et les femmes le sont
tous
mais il ya une situation différente
foulée zone pour les femmes c'est que
quand une femme quand un homme fait une
crise quand il est quand il est bon
quand il va mal il bat sa femme
quand une femme fait une crise elle est
battue c'est à dire que dans les deux
cas c'est toujours la femme battue
je pense que pour tourner j'ai été battu
en fait mon mari me laisse pas du tout
supposer que ça et ça s'est passé en
fait au moment où je n'ai pas très bien
et j'avais invité en effet des états
unis
c'est uniquement des femmes qui ont
discuté ensemble dans son camp une île
absolument pas supporté que tu aimes pas
être là de passer à ces discussions etc
je voudrais dire encore une chose parce
que j'ai entendu il arrive aussi qu'un
homme passe à côté du but
je suppose qu effectivement donc pour
appartenir à un autre c'est justement
parce qu'il ya des gens qui ne croient
que tout le problème arrive c'est qu'il
ya une mauvaise compréhension de ce
qu'est le couple à partir du moment où
vous et avisé dans une société comme la
nôtre des principes de hiérarchie on
fausse tous les problèmes le couple et
existe et ne peut exister quand tu aimes
terme de complémentarité
si vous ne comprenez pas cette notion de
complémentarité et si on la comprenait à
tous les niveaux socio politique
également
on n'aurait pas les problèmes que nous
avons eu une maladie parce que vraiment
monsieur qui est médecin à dean parole
vraiment je trouve mais lloris entre la
violence motivée mémoire des comptes
comme c'est grave de dire une chose
pareille
quels sont les critères des motifs à
partir de quelle faute
une femme est sanctionné à partir de
alors quel est le degré des coûts liés à
la paix qu'a dit et puis à la fosse
grâce c'est pas ça de la violence dans
les trains je ne le suis pas du tout je
sais pas le panégyrique des de la
violence la haine ni ce n'est pas ça
n'est pas comprendre un problème que
que de laisser une situation si on met
pas la violence mais je n'excuse rien
madame je vous explique les violences
motivées à mon sens est bien beau tout
d'ailleurs vous avez dit quelque chose
madame que je peux pas laisser passer
sans relever vous avez dit que les
femmes dans les pays sous développés
vous avez dit c'est pas comme dans les
pays sous développés à vous avez dit moi
de le dire je dois le relever c'est très
important une notion complètement fausse
la situation dernière les pays
sous-développés match et je dois le dire
parce que c'est très important parce que
justement il existe dans ces soit disant
pays sous développés une leçon que sur
le plan matériel et pas sur le reste
donc le terme jeu là bas eh bien il
existe dans ces pays pour les femmes des
possibilités de répondre et de
rééquilibrer le problème entre autres
parce que l on entre entre entre leur
malchance satirique sur la place du
village qui leur fait bar sur les
activités des hommes mais à partir du
moment où nous avons fausser les
problèmes d'ailleurs notre grand tort a
été comme avons été dans ces soit disant
pays de fausser le jeu et de faire voir
que la femme est un objet qu'on vend
qu'on achète ce qu'ils font quand on
connaît le problème est seulement
malheureusement avec les spécialistes
qu'ils connaissent alors la plupart des
gens ignorent cet aspect de la femme
dans ces pays il est bien il faut dire
que si dans nos pays justement la femme
se trouve dans certaines situations
graves
c'est une situation qui comme vous avez
semblé le dire tout à l'heure c'est
gratuit ce n'est pas vrai ça ne peut pas
être gratuit
imaginez ceux ci vous avez l'homme
l'être humain la femme également
d'ailleurs et d'un accumulateur où un
barrage qu'on remplit d'eau une force
qui s'accumulent en lui il faut
automatiquement qu'une décharge
si par exemple vous avez été agressée
toute la journée dans votre travail
eh bien vous accumulez en vous une
certaine masse de violence qui doit se
décharger vous le décharger quand vous
rentrez là mais la peur des coups sur le
gosse le bios qui reçoit les goûts se
décharge sur la porte qu'il prenne un
coup de pied sur le chat sur le sien
c'est de la psychologie et le monde mais
ça ça passe
si le maire rentrer en voiture c'est à
dire une queue de poisson il s'est fait
traiter de sale ce que je dis par le
voisin et il n'a pas pu répondre
il rentre à la maison une mauvaise
humeur pour ça se passe sur quelqu'un
est la première personne c'est la femme
si ce n'est pas la belle merde c'est pas
le gosse c'est pas le chat pas le chef
mois alors c'est pour dire donc il ya
déjà des réactions de cet ordre qui
existait un premier prêt bien série de
réactions de violence qui sont le
résultat
je ne dis pas ça pour excuser le
problème n'est pas d'excuser les uns au
détriment des autres le problème est
d'essayer d'y voir clair
donc c'est par la totalité des aspects
qui est l'éventail est très complexe et
c passable
bon il ya maintenant l'aspect de
l'impuissance c'est à dire qu'il ya un
être humain qui se trouve impuissant
vis-à-vis par exemple de sa partenaire
impuissant à un niveau par exemple il
n'a pas d'argent elle à l'arche un bon
il ya un phénomène là où il est dans un
état d'infériorité par rapport à ce qui
est le critère normal dans une société
il va lui en vouloir partir il va lui en
vouloir
ça peut se traduire par des d'autres cas
la femme est ce qu'on appelle la
mignonne elle est jolie elle est
adorable mais se rend pas compte qu'elle
aimait gère c'est à dire que l influence
des pics elle agace elle le provoque
il y a une façon morale de baffes et les
femmes très souvent s'y emploie avec
admiration vraiment elles sont très très
fortes dans cette part parce qu'elles
sont aussi intelligente sinon plus que
les hommes très souvent et très fine
psychologue
elles savent où piqué le résultat
l'homme est impuissant à répondre au
même niveau si bas
je pense que j'ai besoin de retrouver le
rythme rapidement
l'impuissance sexuelle l'homme qui est
impuissant sexuellement est atteint dans
sa virilité et les prouve le besoin
d'affirmer de se réconforter de
retrouver sa virilité ailleurs s'ils
sont toujours à tort dans la porte
écoutez j'ai des réactions un petit peu
partout mais aussi moi je vois pour le
cas de mon mari mon mari a été élevée
par une mère qui est qui est en
adoration devant lui de lui elle a fait
un dieu sa soeur après vient derrière
dell lui c'est tout moi moi il ya des
choses que je me refuse à faire quand il
partait à la chasse ce matin à 5 heures
du matin mais y'a pas de raison que je
me lève pour faire son déjeuner il a été
à le faire alors cela ne m'était pas
benziane senouci chez des couples ça y
est je pense que ma fille ne voulait
répondre aussi oui je veux dire que dans
ce tableau
enfin il est ce qu'il est à fait
monsieur là un instant on a envie de
penser pauvre zone oui bon alors je
crois que je crois que c'est toujours
pareil pour les hommes parlent de ça ils
parlent pour eux oui c'est ça ils vont
il faut que ce sont les femmes qui s est
alors je 3 je crois que tout le monde a
bien pu voir la différence qu'ils
avaient effectivement par exemple entre
ces messieurs qui parle bon et puis le
petit reportage qui a lu au début quand
les indices mais non ils baissent pas
leurs femmes et puis les femmes qui
disent moi je suis battu pourquoi alors
ce que je crois que ce que beaucoup
d'entre nous ont remarqué c'est
qu'effectivement elle risque d'être
battues elles le sont effectivement si
elles peuvent pas s'échapper quand elle
se révolte contre une situation
d'oppression ou les matières les hommes
alors tout à l'heure monsieur parlait de
ce que de la façon dont les femmes
j'ai pas comment il a dit mme enfin
disons en gros qu'ils auraient tendance
à asticoter les hommes et à leur dire
des choses alors envoyer des piques
l.sané l'année sanela déjà qu'une
première une première révolte des femmes
contre une situation
elle voulait pas qu'elle voulait pas
faire ce que lui demander l'homme est
tenue on pensait que c'était juste
qu'elle le fasse
elle se défend avec des mots si les mots
l'homme peut pas y répond parce que de
fait hinault il ne peut pas y répondre
étape partie je pense néanmoins que
c'est vrai que nous vivons dans une
société qui est violence il faut le
déplorer
c'est vrai que l'homme subit des
frustrations qui sont constantes
c'est vrai qu'il se sent agressé mais la
femme aussi ce son est alors pourquoi la
femme subir et à la violence de l'homme
je crois que justement l'intérêt c'est
de faire quelque chose dans lequel le
recours ne soit pas la violence et tout
à l'heure au début de l'émission
j'ai été un peu choqué parce que on
disait je crois que c'était vous madame
qui disiez la seule réponse à la
violence c'est finalement la première
fois c'est ça alors sur ce joueur
je ne sais pas je ne suis pas d'accord
les fans justin je voudrais dire
simplement deux mots c'est que pour
comprendre un problème il faudrait être
aussi objective que possible
et là nous sommes en train de passionnés
le débat de nous séparer en deux clans à
être clan féministe et clan masculin si
je puis dire
et donc c'est en cherchant une
explication qu'on pourrait aboutir à un
résultat
et moi je donne des explications d'ordre
médical il va de soi qu'il y à d'autres
explications
mais ça n'est pas en récré minant et en
prenant d'une façon systématique la
partie qu'on pourrait faire avancer les
choses mais c'est par ici
oui n'est ce pas je crois qu'il n'est
pas nécessaire de chercher des
explications aussi compliqué et je ne
pense pas comme le croit madame que si
une femme se rebellaient contre la brute
qu'elle a à côté d'elle elle obtiendrait
un résultat au contraire l'expérience
que j'ai et qui porte sur un nombre 1
extrêmement nombreux deux cas c'est qu'à
la base de tout ça il ya comme le disait
très justement le docteur tout à l'heure
l'alcoolisme
c'est ça la première course et
l'alcoolisme et vous avez alors le cas
typique le l'homme le mari qui est allé
boire qui arrange que nous l'avons
abordé de salaire mais si cette porte
dès maintenant je préfère dévier la
question est de chercher et de chercher
une quantité des causes accessoires
alors que là c'est la cause principale
et je pense que là la malheureuse femme
n'a aucune chance d'échapper à son sort
madame attendait madame j
comment voulez dire que le jury il mais
ça va mon avis un homme qui bat sa femme
est un malade qui s'ignore séoudite vous
parlez d'alcoolisme et ça peut très bien
d'autres choses
l'admission sa réponse était pas le cas
poursuit bel imaginaire
pourquoi pourquoi une femme battue reste
ce thème à la mode il vous plait
énormément deux raisons la première
c'est grâce aux élèves son mari parti
pendant vingt ans nous avons formé un
maillage très très uni il est impensable
de quitter mon mari ou que mon mari me
quittes
en plus de ça il y avait cinq enfants je
me voyais très mal elle vend seuls mes
cinq enfants dont trois garçons et deux
filles
c'est pour moi voyez vous c'est de la
lâcheté de la femme de la part de la
femme de se laisser battre
pourquoi parce que on n'a pas les moyens
des moyens pécunier pour élever ses
enfants
on se sent mais en intériorité vis-à-vis
des autres femmes qui l ont toujours
travaillé on a passé 20 ans de sa vie à
élever ses enfants à s'occuper de son
mari à ce que 800 ménages
donc on n'a pas participé si vous voulez
la vie active c'est un très gros
handicap qui fait qu' on attend on
tergiverse
oui vous madame vous parler de ça a duré
vingt ans et mais par exemple dans le
cas de madame x qui est beaucoup plus
jeune qui est même très jeune
vous êtes parti tout de suite madame
commencent à se contenter de corps avait
décidé de le quitter s'est ainsi pas il
s'est trouvé en face à ça fait petit à
petit mais il s'est trouvé que l'accueil
le soir même où ça s'est passé comme des
amis étaient encore là elles ont
immédiatement emmené parce que j'étais
complètement la route c'est le cas de le
dire elle - emmené avec mon enfant léger
j'étais hébergé d'une belle pendant deux
trois jours
lorsque je suis revenue tout était cassé
il avec avait vraiment bien une crise de
rage et petit à petit en fait on du fait
qu'ils avaient la librairie des femmes
que petit à petit j'ai connu des femmes
à cet endroit là ça m'a permis de me
garer mans partir parce que je n'étais
pas possible ça fait casser quelque
chose en moi aussi très très fort je
m'attendais à ce qu'on ressent dans tout
le courrier que nous avons su et là je
voudrais et un extrait d'une lettre
c'est justement le grand isolement et la
grande détresse des femmes seules
téléspectatrices qui nous écrit qui nous
écrit une longue lettre et qui dit je
chante je songe depuis toujours à m'en
aller elle est mariée depuis plus de 20
ans elle aussi je les fais dix fois mais
je me suis chaque fois arrêté pourquoi
oui pourquoi au début parce que j'étais
très jeune
parce que nous étions dans une misère
noire et que je pensais que la situation
s'améliorera en s'améliorant les choses
iraient mieux
ma mère me disait quand il n'ya pas de
fourrure ateliers les chevaux se bat
ensuite parce que j'ai eu trois enfants
et que tout le monde ait prêché la
patience parce que je n'avais pas de
métier parce que j'étais toute seule
dans la vie n'ayant plus aucune famille
et parce qu'à part ses crises de
violence mon mari est un brave homme et
qu'il m'aime comment peut-on aimer un
homme qui vous bat comme ça avec autant
de constance maxi probablement qu'on
aime d'abord avant qu'il ait commencé à
vous battre
j'imagine c'est à dire qu'on a essayé de
me faire les choses par le commencement
c'est à dire d'établir un couple qui est
très difficile et ce qu'on l'a on sait
de moins en moins et une fois qu'on a
établi un couple qu'on s'aime s'il
apparaît certains phénomènes c'est que
effectivement on ne sait pas comment
faire durer un couple car le fort mais
c'est assez facile de faire durer c'est
beaucoup plus difficile ça implique une
notion qui est celle du noviciat c'est à
dire une notion dans lequel les angles
aigus que l'on possède tout un chacun
doit être rappelé pour que ça ne blesse
pas le voisin signala qu'un dans le
couple qu'il fait et je voudrais dire
madame qui est là qui croient que je
suis simplement du côté des hommes et
pas du côté des femmes que ce que je dis
est aussi valable au niveau d'une femme
ce sont des ressorts psychologiques qui
peuvent être non seulement ceux d'un
homme mais ceux d'une femme et que si
l'un ou l'autre la femme ou l'homme ne
se prête pas à cette espèce de mise en
condition pour former un couple
eh bien on blesse l'autre quel qu'il
soit forme femmes et arrive un moment où
le cours commence à se désagréger
alors maintenant on sen l'homme se met à
vous battre pour une raison ou pour une
autre parce que je ne crois pas moi
combattre sans raison ça ne me ça me
paraît tout à fait improbable à moins
d'être avoir un atavisme de calan si
dans le cas voilà un atavisme de
violence où on est un sadique ces deux
nouveaux quais des réactions vous avez
des cas où il ya des syndicats bien sûr
mais il ya aussi des cas où il ya des
pommes qui aime son peuple des rapports
et sado maso ça existe aussi
alors vous comprenez il faut quand même
se dire et on n'en parle pas
volontairement parce que le problème
n'est pas grave à ce niveau là sion et
n'ont rien le niveau est grave au niveau
d'une pas mais la nature qui subissent
là qui ne peut pas parce qu'elle n'a pas
la force physique sans dépendre parce
que la société la protège pas il faut
donc faire en sorte qu'elle soit
protégée
il faut faire en sorte qu'elle puisse
aller quelque part ça c'est d'accord
morts partout même faudrait quand même
si elle m'a minutes et moynier sur notre
plateau aujourd'hui était en train de
vous expliquer que les alentours de
force était peut-être note est abaissée
dimanche de la situation j'étais parce
que ce qui se serait passé
j'étais très surprise tellement c'est le
fait de la violence qui est en face ils
l'ont monsieur le commissaire sinon
qu'elle recourra les femmes alors il
faut qu'elle aille au commissariat avec
des marques des marques physiques de
violence où on ne peut pas dire à une
femme qu'il faut qu'elle vienne au
commissariat c'est elle qui doit en
prendre l'initiative
oui mais si elle vient si elle vient au
commissariat et il faut d'abord qu'elle
manifeste sa volonté de déposer plainte
d'une manière concrète c'est à dire en
faisant une déclaration par procès
verbal et en la signant la police n'est
pas un organisme qui travaille dans le
secret
car ce que chez nous ce qui compte c'est
ce qui est écrit ce qui n'est pas écrit
ne compte pas et la suite de la faire eh
bien elle est conditionnée par le
certificat médical que la femme
plaignante et je répète bien qu'ils
aient plaignante elle soit apportera si
c'est un certificat médical qui comporte
huit jours ou moins de huit jours
d'arrêt de travail c'est une
contravention
c'est un peu si vous voulez comme les
contraventions au code de la route
c'est à dire bon eh bien c'est à dire
que là il y aura aujourd'hui ce sera une
amende une amende légère
bon bien que ça pourrait entraîner
quelques jours de prison il faut
reconnaître que dans ce genre de
violences est jours de prison ça
n'existe pas bon si vous dépassez si
vous allez au delà de neuf jours c'est
un délit à ce moment là c'est un délit
donc la peine de prison pour est
juridiquement être importante et
pourrait même atteindre plusieurs années
d'appel que d'après le code mais en fait
sauf dans les cas très graves ou des
femmes ont des fractures et ça m'est
arrivé dans mon métier est d'avoir des
femmes qui avait été battu qu'avec des
bras fracturés ou ou même une fois je me
rappelle le crâne fracturé alors
évidemment à ce moment là c'est très
grave ça peut même devenir un crime et
l'action de la police dans ce cas là est
déterminante parce que celui qui frappe
sa femme avec une telle violence c'est
un individu extrêmement dangereux et il
peut être appréhendé en flagrant délit
par la police et avec l'autorisation des
magistrats il peut être incarcéré
je pense qu'on a pas vu nos
téléspectatrices une
am qui a subi des violences si elle
devient ont parlé oui c'est à ça que mon
mari m'a cassé d'un coup de pied m'a
cassé le péroné ce qui nécessite l
approche de la jambe de quelques mois
d'arrêt j'ai porté plainte c'est un fait
mais enfin lorsque ces mewtwo devant ce
tribunal
plusieurs années après c'est très long
les faits mais des plus si chaud si vous
voulez alors madame si vous voulez
retourner vers mon deuxième voie de
droite ronin monsieur parizeau qui soit
et je crois là pour répondre à cette
question de la lenteur de la procédure
c'est ça on dessine et il communique mal
oui oui il est en forme en examen ce
temps où on a besoin on a recours à
l'assistance judiciaire ont rejeté sans
moyens sans rien donc j'étais obligé
d'avoir recours à l'assistance
judiciaire
donc vous savez tout comme moi que cette
raison de 10 hier n'est pas nécessaire
quand vous portez plainte au point de
vue pénal n'est ce pas mais la procédure
risque d'être aussi longue néanmoins
tout ça c'est dû à la correctionnelle
comment je m'excuse ça et passer en
correctionnelle c'est le passé en
correctionnelle a tellement
mais avant que ça ne passe en
correctionnelle et ça dépend de vous
pouvez attendre 6 mois vous pouvez aussi
attendre de zones peu denses
on mettra 100 si les pratiques médicales
dont on parlait tout à l'heure le
certificat médical dont on parlait tout
à leurs dépens du médecin ce qui vous
arrive souvent lecteurs de délivrer de
certificat médical
est-ce que c'est pas un grand problème
de conscience qui n'est pas discutée
cette situation d'espèces dans mon
quartier je ne
fait pas des certificats de tous les
jours mais enfin il m'arrive de rédiger
des certificats de constatation de coups
et blessures
je ne peux pas dire que ça aille très
très loin je viens aux pattes ils sont
peut-être les gens je pense qu'elle
souhaite alternative créer ou à
l'intention de créer un refuge qui
serait peut-être une des solutions en
tout cas provisoire pour les femmes
battues
alors qu'il soit une solution évidemment
d'échapper à la violence
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
essayons de créer un centre ce centre
nous ne l'avons pas encore très car les
moyens nous aurons la même giroud a
néanmoins promis de nous donner à
l'hôtel maternelle désaffecté alors
c'est un problème c'est une c'est une
façon d'échapper pour les femmes la
violence elle deviendrait la avec leurs
enfants et l excuse en venant là en tant
que ce centre vous allez les femmes se
mettent se met encore à couper la loi
dit c'est elle qui ont quitté le
domicile conjugal
oui à l'appeler ce que nous leur
demandons à sur le plan s'il voulait
légal ce que nous faisons avant
lorsqu'elle nous téléphonent de nom le
numéro de téléphone d'un médecin ce
médecin s'il ya eu des coups fait les
constats nécessaires elles vont ensuite
au commissariat de police avec le
certificat médical et elles disent
qu'elles sont obligées d'abandonner le
domicile conjugal en raison du danger
que cela représente pour eux et nous
faisons parallèlement une plainte au
procureur et lorsque nous introduisons
le report nous faisons une régate
autorisant la femme a résidé séparément
dès le début de la procédure
donc c'est faisable non qu'elle se sent
là un tout petit peu protégés et elle
peut bien roulé un moyen technique ces
quelques moyens techniques qui sont
longs qui actuellement sont tolérées
justement c'est pour sur le plan
technique pour essayer de les aider que
nous avons proposé un avant-projet de
loi visant à sanctionner les violences
répétées des ce projet de loi si vous
voulez se divise en deux parties d'une
part l'aménagement de la preuve
actuellement sont les femmes qui doivent
prouver qu'elles ont reçu des coups
c'est extrêmement difficile
alors nous nous ce que nous proposons
c'est que sur un simple aveu que la
femme isoc elle a reçu les coups
une enquête immédiatement soit
diligentée par la police de façon à voir
si véritablement c'est à maris violents
le concubin violent car cela arrive
aussi pour les cubains alors ça c'est le
premier mot poids de notre projet de
joueurs mais cette enquête croyez-vous
je m'excuse quelle base quelles aboutir
à quelque chose entre l'instant où une
femme est battue quand elle ne veut pas
lire
lorsque les bananes ne savent pas c'est
à dire que si vous les mayas ne le
doivent pas aider quelqu'un qui n'a pas
choisi une fois pour toutes deux parties
quelqu'un qui n'a pas choisi d'aider ne
pouvons pas prendre la solution à sa
place ce que nous pouvons faire c'est
créer une assistance technique créer
quelque chose dans lequel plus tard
puisque nous n'avons pas encore ce santé
les femmes vivront ensemble se
retrouveront ensemble créer une grande
communauté de femmes et de leurs enfants
qu'ils soient pour elle un moyen
d'échapper à la violence parce que nous
considérons pariez vous que ce serait ma
dame m'a la musique je suis obligé de
vous interrompre lui arrivant au terme
de notre émission en tout cas nous
n'avons bien sûr pas fait le tour de ce
problème car ils vivent mais si c'est un
problème face tout le monde se tient
très nombreux tout le monde n'a pas pu
dire ce qu'il avait à dire
mais peut-être avons-nous quand même
tenter de rendre service vous avez une
adresse à que j'ai deux nuits au
téléphone à des dérives jasmin 67,80
l'après midi c'est notre numéro d'appel
jaillissement 67 81 et 967 48,37 le soir
et à midi alors j'avais mal 37 81 et 967
voulait bien répéter 967 48,35 nucletron
et le mat bien merci merci à vous tous
d'être resté à notre écoute je vous
souhaite une excellente fin de journée
au revoir à bientôt
[Musique]